la rue n'est pas à la hauteur de l'homme
alon leonier qui se souvient de
Jean-Paul mazaro qui se souvient de ce
célèbrebéniste sous Napoléon I il
meublait les châteaux et les demeures
bourgeoises qui se souvient de cet homme
aux idées progressistes amis et Mesen de
Gustave
Courbet sans lui le musée de lonce le
Sonier ne serait pas ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui messieurs dames bienvenue
pour cette présentation consacrée à
Jean-Paul mazaro être mescè du musée au
19e siècle Jean-Paul mazaro est né en
1823 son père est relieur grâce à une
bourse du département du Jura il part
étudier à Dijon puis travailler à Paris
regardez son bas relief en bois et cette
nymphe c'est certain il a des doigts en
or le succès va arriver au salon de
1855 quand il va présenter ce grand
bahu qui foisonne de décor de menuiserie
va être présenté au Salon de 1855 va
remporter la première médaille d'argent
et va être acheté par l'empereur
Napoléon I pour son palais de saint-clou
il ne reste que des photos du fameux
meuble de mazaro le palais et ses
trésors ont été détruits pendant la
guerre de
1870 être acheté par l'empereur c'est
l'assurance d'une belle carrière mazaro
a épousé la fille de son patron pierre
ba les affaires sont bonnes devenu riche
les bénistes achètent des œuvres d'art
c'est un collectionneur et il n'oublie
pas d'où il vient il répond à l'appel du
conservateur du tout jeune musée de
lonce qui cherche des
mescenes et il souhaite et bien rendre
tout simplement ce qui lui a été donné
et participer ainsi à l'éducation
susciter des vocations d'artiste en
offrant des œuvres de qualité si c'est
la mission également qu'il sait
donné mazaro aura offert au total une
centaine d'œuvres d'art au musée de Lon
le sonniier tout a été écrit et
consigné ce qui est original c'est
qu'effectivement mazaro va donner dès
son plus jeune âge dès qu'il élève
finalement il va offrir des œuvres au
musée de Lon et puis il va très
régulièrement sur donc une période de 40
ans offrir des tableaux des des objets
divers et ça c'est quelque chose
d'original il va donner de son vivant
des œuvres de sa propre collection et
des œuvres qu'il va acheter pour le
musée de lance à la fin de sa vie
Jean-Paul mazaro donnera au musée quatre
œuvres de son ami Gustave Courbet ils
sont tous les deux comptois installés à
Paris artist progressistes entre les
deux hommes la connivance est
évidente I